the c-130 cargo plane might not be the
first aircraft that the public
associates with the elite aerobatic
squadron the Blue Angels
but with marine captain Katie Higgins of
the controls
the Blue Angels c-130 known as Fat
Albert is a crowd favorite Higgins who
has flown this type of military
workhorse cargo plane in Uganda and
Afghanistan with the Blue Angels first
female pilot to fly during shows though
Fat Albert isn't as faster as
maneuverable as the Blue Angels fa-18
Hornet Jets Higgins makes the big plane
dance
Higgins executes flat passes at 50 feet
simulates tactical landings and puts the
plane to do a nosedive so steep and fast
but some of fat Albert's goes
when Higgins lands she pops a wheelie
well as much of a wheelie of a cargo
plane can manage and then she reverses
Fat Albert crops and makes the big guy
moonwalk